[Music]
Hannity tweeted I talked to hundreds of
women at Fox this week both on Aronoff
they say it all BS Brit Hume - Brit why
didn't gretchen quit and sue instead of
suing only after she got fired
why didn't she complain why didn't she
complain really he means the anonymous
hotline yeah I did the harassment
seminar twice I never heard about a
hotline cuz it's [ __ ] they have a
contractual right to monitor our
communications a hotline in this
building is like a complaint box in
occupied Paris it's like we're telling
women go on speak up for yourself just
know the entire network is with Roger no
one will believe you they'll call you a
liar oh and as for your career you want
the Simons and airtime go ahead call the
paranoid man who decides your salary a
pervert and do that on a [ __ ]
anonymous hotline he controls on a phone
he has a contractual right to record
jesus [ __ ] christ do you think women
are idiots it's like somebody stripped
you naked and they want you to walk
through this office just to [ __ ]
prove it okay
can I see you for a minute
I don't know but I like a goddamn Dairy
Queen you don't get to go and get
whatever you want everybody on my shows
knows the meaning of decency and I do
mean everybody a TV outfit needs tough
confident women do I push them you bet
your ass I do
but have I ever demanded sex during a
casting session I defy you to find any
evidence that a single part of what
these women are saying is true get ready
more will come we need to let Rupert
know what it means if I lose
retching Carlson could kill Fox News
this is a fight for your jobs if I don't
you go the only job I have ever won in
it I don't want to be on TV I want to be
on Fox uh-huh my family every day
especially holidays you want to fox news
wax boxes how we do Church
you know when they made the corn and
logotype his folks had buck burned into
their TV screens back to us Kayla you're
not getting fired
he cannot scale his anger he's a
perpetual outrage machine that's what
crazies love him no offense to your
family you want to do the folders no
Crockett Fox no one really wins by suing
Fox News it's been our experience and
once you go public in your job no one
will hire you if you're able to stick it
out at Fox gather more evidence you
might be able to sue Ailes himself
instead of Fox and that is why I'm here
because Marty Hyman told me that over
here in New Jersey I can avoid
arbitration by suing Roger personally he
says that you've managed to change the
law and that we could call other women
and show a pattern will other women come
forward yes they will you live and work
in New York
Roger has a house in Burton County where
he stays when he can't make it upstate
it did your homework Miss Carlson no
fingerprints that's how much I practiced
the violinists a child if Ryder finds
out you came to us he won't just fire
you he will bang us with a million
dollar lawsuit he will attack you
personally these men they care more
about their reputations than they do
money Roger won't stop oh I know you
know that colleagues you admire will say
publicly you're a superior ambitious
woman who's suing because her career
stalled let him you have to adopt the
mentality of an Irish streak huh the
world is a bad place people are lazy
morons minorities are criminals sex is
sick but interesting ask yourself what
would scare my grandmother or piss off
my grandfather and that's a [ __ ] story
makes so much sense women are everywhere
well let them play golf and tennis now
you charge on the phone cuz you call me
skirt yeah yeah attitude off camera was
even worse you're a man hater learn to
get along with the boys you're sexy but
you're too much work I have a whole list
we'll other women comes forward you may
have heard there was a dust-up involving
yours truly in presidential contender
Donald Trump it was blood coming out of
her eyes blood coming out of her
wherever God did he just accuse me of
ingre men straining wait am I gonna be
the story no I'm gonna be the story no
nobody stops for watching because of a
conflict they stopped watching when
there isn't one I want to convince you
that I belong on air mr. Reyes I think
I'd be freaking phenomenal on your
network I could pluck you out and move
you to the front of the line but I need
to know that you're loyal I need you to
find a way to prove it
[Music]
even though I Ron just got that door
blocking his office someone has to speak
up someone has to get mashed FoxNews
star Brechin carlson dropped a major
bomb shell today because she's doing
this could kill Fox News we need
everyone on Team Watcher get it on put
it on these are at the end times
you do understand I have to be above
this right and you know the entire
country is talking about your period
right now sweetheart
this is an island of safety and truth
[Music]
ready to go to war oh yeah
[Music]
you
[Music]